okay this is really important the Trump
administration has documents showing
they know how many people might die if
states open too quickly it's a big
number and those documents have now
leaked of course the Trump
administration is not talking publicly
about any of this so when we asked the
question how many people will die of
coronavirus there is not one answer a
way of modeling there are confidence
intervals the death toll depends on
things that we can't control like how
contagious is coronavirus what is the
bottom line
death rate the fatality rate of the
virus the death toll also depends on
things we can control like social
distancing whether we open States too
early whether we find a treatment or a
vaccine now publicly the Trump
administration has taken the approach of
claiming that the baseline if he did
nothing would have been 2.2 million
deaths Trump often says I could have
done nothing and 2.2 million people
would have died but I've done stuff so
we're gonna be way below that now no
president could really get away with
doing nothing once you start mitigation
the possible death toll starts to
decline one model said could be a
hundred and fifty to two hundred and
fifty thousand another said could be one
to two hundred thousand and eventually
as more and more governors closed down
projections kept improving down to
roughly sixty to seventy thousand deaths
for wave one in which we are right now
the wave one thing is important because
more and more medical experts think
there will be a second wave of the virus
starting in the fall possibly a third
wave in 2021 okay let's put that aside
for now the important question now is
after going through weeks of mitigation
what would happen if we reopen States
too early we had a record single day
death toll this week we are have very
high numbers of deaths we are still
finding 25,000 or more new cases every
single day in the United States we're
hopefully in the peak the peak is a
plateau it can last a month or so if we
do everything right so when Texas and
Georgia and other states plan to reopen
tomorrow and Monday and other days next
week it's very risky now Trump was asked
a few days ago are you worried about a
resurgence in the virus if States open
too quickly
have you modeled what those numbers
would look like and
Trump said if we did nothing we would
have lost two million people now we
won't the truth though is we know that
they do have models about what happens
if they open too early and they're
really really bad before we look at the
models here's Trump's answer when he was
asked about this a few days ago we were
talking about up to 2.2 million deaths
so that's five times almost what we lost
in the civil war okay if everything
happens properly and if we continue to
go the way we're going now we will be
significantly less than the lowest
number with mitigation so we'll be
significantly less and it's a lot of
people now Trump first of all didn't
answer saying if I did nothing we would
have 2.2 million deaths the question was
have you modeled what would happen if
you open too early the answer is a
simple yes and we have those models
Trump gave that ridiculous answer on
April 17th but in early April the
federal government put together models
of what happens if social distancing
stops too quickly and the numbers are
anywhere from a middle-of-the-road guess
of 300,000 deaths all the way up to 1.8
million deaths this is a model from the
Department of Health and Human Services
Trump's administration had the data in
early April but Trump gave a bogus
answer
we now have their models and they are
very concerning the Department of HHS
has four scenarios and then they have
like a best guess which is in the middle
the models range from 94 thousand deaths
up to 1.8 million deaths Trump likes to
say thanks to me we'll have 60,000
deaths instead of 2.2 million it's
absurd but thanks to opening too early
you could have 1.8 million deaths
instead of 60,000 the best scenario
expects 94 thousand deaths there are
some in-between models up all the way up
to one which they
1.8 million deaths and then you have a
sort of average of these a best guess
right now which says if you open too
early about 300,000 people are going to
die so there are multiple things to
think about here
first Trump was asked have you modeled
this and he didn't answer it's possible
he saw this model but he won't admit it
that's a problem of dishonesty it's
possible he didn't even see it
that's a problem of Trump often not
having the facts because he lacks the
attention span to actually absorb that
information number two if Trump wants to
take credit for 60 K instead of 2
million he would have to take
responsibility for 300 K or a million or
1.8 million instead of 60 K if it's a
result of states opening too early
thanks to his public posturing about
opening up the economy now over the last
24 hours he has finally said you know I
think maybe George is opening up too
early and it's possible someone got to
him and said you can't be on the side of
encouraging this because it's going to
be really bad but the most important
takeaway is the government has the data
they know the risks and they have the
numbers and yet Trump and Fox News have
mostly still been fomenting these
freedom and liberty protests around the
country from people just demanding that
governors let it rip people will die we
now know that they know it and the next
thing I want to talk about is the
astroturfed protesters that we have seen
real quick I want to tell you about our
sponsor magic spoon who have done
something awesome they've taken all of
our favorite sugary childhood cereals
that we know we shouldn't eat anymore
and turn them into something you can
actually feel good about eating as an
adult there's four flavors cocoa fruity
frosted and blueberry they taste great
they're crunchy they're sweet like you
would expect this type of cereal to be
but it's perfect for a ketogenic diet
because one Bowl has only three net
carbs 12 grams of protein it's
sugar-free gluten-free grain free soy
free once our team tried magic spoon for
the first time we actually ended up
emailing magic spoon back and saying can
you send us more boxes send more samples
they've been a big hit with David Pakman
show
staffers and magic spoon
knows how delicious their cereal is
because if you don't like it they'll
refund all of your money no questions
asked and you'll get free shipping when
you go to magic spoon dot-com slash
Pakman and use the code Pakman that's PA
que ma n